As we get into social perspectives on literature and art,
uh,
you may ask yourself,
out of idle curiosity or perhaps even peevishly,
why Marx,
why so much marks?
Why is it marks who seems to stand behind the idea that the social criticism of
art is the best and most relevant way to approach the subject matter?
Uh,
well it's because
whatever the outcome of Marxists thought may have proven to be historically,
it's nevertheless the case,
uh,
to this day that the most devastating critique of existing ideas about things of
states of affairs that,
uh,
as it were me along without too much self consciousness remains the Marxist one
together.
Perhaps with the Freud in one and when we turned to Jameson next time we'll see
that in both cases and we'll be working a little bit with this today too.
When we turned to Benyamin,
uh,
we'll see that in both cases it has to do with the way in which,
um,
we are brought up short by the kind of criticism which argues that somehow
standing behind a,
our conception of reality and our understanding of our place in the world.
There is one form or another of the unconscious.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
arguably,
in this course in literary theory,
first taken up notions of a linguistic,
uh,
unconscious or in any case,
linguistic preconditioning then taken up notions of a psychoanalytic unconscious
and now,
uh,
in the very title of Jameson's book from which we'll be considering an excerpt
in the next lecture,
uh,
we have the notion of the political unconscious.
There are other ways of effecting a social criticism of literature and art,
uh,
from the right.
Uh,
there's the,
there's an extraordinary book by Leo Strauss on Aristophanes together with his
great readings of the traditional texts of political philosophy.
Uh,
there is of course a very strong liberal tradition of criticism,
particularly in the public sphere and the journalism of the public's fear.
Uh,
perhaps the most notable proponent of a liberal criticism of art undertaken from
a social point of view is the work collected in Lionel trilling,
the literal,
the liberal imagination.
So there are options,
but by far,
the most pervasive mode of social critique,
uh,
in literary theory and in the modern history of thinking about literature,
remains the Marxist one our concern because we are,
uh,
as much as we can be and working through these materials,
our concern is of course,
primarily with Marxist aesthetics.
What are the options,
uh,
for a Marxist critic,
um,
in aesthetic terms.
Uh,
and that's,
uh,
and that's of course what we're going to be taking up,
in a moment.
And also when we turn to,
uh,
Fredric Jameson on Thursday.
But in the meantime,
what about marks that,
I mean,
I think I can take it for granted.
Uh,
and of course of this kind,
most of you have some familiarity with the history of ideas,
uh,
and with Western culture.
I think I can take it for granted that,
that,
that most of you have some notion,
just as you have some notion about Freud,
you have some notion of what Mark's is all about.
Um,
of particular importance for the kinds of criticism we undertake to read in this
moment of the course is,
uh,
of course the idea of ideology,
now ideology in the writings of both marks and angles and in,
uh,
all the,
the sort of complex history,
uh,
of the writings that have succeeded them.
They were founders of discursivity.
Uh,
and there has been great debate within the Marxist tradition.
Ideology is a term about which there has never been a wholehearted agreement.
Primarily the disagreement concerning ideology in this tradition has to do with
whether or not a ideology ought properly to be,
uh,
to be ascribed to conscious as well as to unconscious,
preconceptions about the world.
In other words,
if I know I'm really to the core perfectly well that the moon is made of green
cheese,
uh,
I can prove it.
Uh,
I have no doubt about it.
It's not something that I'm unaware that I think then and which,
but at the same time,
if my opinion,
my belief,
my expression of fact,
uh,
to the effect that the moon is great is made of green cheese,
um,
can be a dean is defied as ideology.
The question is,
well,
is it still ideology?
If I'm quite conscious of knowing that the moon is made of green cheese and
prepared to defend my position,
uh,
just as um,
as a kind of belated Aristocrat,
I might be prepared to defend the idea that pre hierarchy and privilege is
appropriate in society.
Um,
perfectly conscious that this is an unpopular idea,
but nevertheless a fully committed to it and prepared to defend it.
The question sometimes in Marxism is,
is this still ideology?
The answer by and large,
particularly in the writings of angles,
perhaps more than in the writings of marks that they answered by and large is
it,
is ideology is essentially the belief that perspective is truth.
That is to say the way in which things appear from the material and economically
grounded standpoint of my own consciousness is not just the way they appear to
me,
but the way they actually are.
Now,
this is a mode of belief,
which in various historical periods,
according to Marx,
has characterized each dominant class in turn with the rise of capitalism.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
the,
the evolution of capitalism into what's called late capitalism.
Of course,
the,
this ideology is primarily what's called the bourgeois ideology.
In other words,
the idea that the various premises on which,
uh,
bourgeois middle class existence is based the premises that have allowed for the
rise and appropriation of power of the middleclass.
The idea,
for example,
of the work ethic,
uh,
the idea of family,
the idea of certain forms of,
of,
of moral behavior,
all of this,
uh,
is ideological and so far as it is supposed to be valid and equally the case for
all in all circumstances at all historical times.
In other words,
the belief that what I see the world to be is just universally the way the world
is.
That is the general characterization of ideology.
Now we've seen this of course,
I mean we began the chorus with the quotation from marks from Marx's Kapital on
commodity fetish fetishism.
We've seen this,
uh,
in the way in which,
um,
it is just spontaneously supposed reflexively without reflection that the labor
properties of something that's produced that is to say the value that can accrue
to it because of the amount of labor that's gone into it is actually something
that inheres in the product itself of Labor.
Uh,
this of course applies as well to art.
And it's something that Benyamin is fully aware of alluding to when he talks
about the aura.
If I forget that art is produced,
that a certain quantum of labor in other words has gone into the,
uh,
the emergence of the work of art.
And if I simply enwrapped contemplative,
uh,
attention address myself to the work of art as itself as though it had objective
value apart from having been produced in a mode of production,
then what I'm doing is commodifying the work of art from Benu means point of
view.
In other words,
to be seduced by the aura of the work of art is in a certain sense to experience
the work of art ideologically as a commodity.
Alright,
now
returning then to the whole question of the aesthetic objectives,
uh,
of Marxist criticism.
There are basically four options.
In other words,
boxes,
criticism has not consistently agreed,
uh,
particularly in it's sort of sophisticated,
versions has not consistently agreed about what the aesthetic of art or actually
to be.
In other words,
how should art reflect society?
How should it constitute a critique of society?
How should it predict and ideal,
uh,
emergent Utopian Society?
Uh,
all of these questions are questions of aesthetic because the way in which art
does,
uh,
express the social is necessarily aesthetic.
It's done through form,
it's done through genre,
it's done as a matter of style.
It's done ultimately,
as the Marxist would say in this or that mode of production.
And all of these mediations of the,
of what you might call the expression of society,
then are understood as the aesthetic in Marxists thought.
And,
and,
and need to be understood in terms of possible options.
The aesthetic of Marx and angles themselves was realist,
but it was a kind of realist that was really rather sophisticated.
When aspiring writers already with the idea that they ought to be writing for
the advancement of the proletariat would right angles.
I'm thinking of 39 La Sal [inaudible].
Other people would sort of send a angles,
manuscripts of their sort of socialist realist novels and angles hated them.
He just,
he just couldn't stand,
uh,
that kind of literature.
And he said,
no,
no.
You don't have to.
You,
you,
you don't have to glorify the proletariat.
You,
you,
you don't have to,
you don't have to project a future in this way.
What you want to do is see in a way that exposes it,
the social dynamic as it exists.
What you want to do is understand the world realistically,
but not 10 denture sleep.
That is to say,
not from an open point of view
angles as literary hero was Balzac who was a royalist reactionary,
but who nevertheless and angles his view,
uh,
was so brilliant in evoking society in all of its manifold complexities,
particularly in the complexity of its class structure,
that this was the model,
uh,
the appropriate model for people hoping to engage in the business of realist
writing.
Now,
this was a motive thought that prevailed largely in Marxists through its early
energetic years,
including the early energetic years of the revolution itself.
In 1927,
the literary philosopher,
Georg Luke Hodge,
l U K,
a,
C s,
who had been a kind of alien theorists of literature,
he'd written,
uh,
a very brilliant book called the theory of the novel,
before he turned to Marxists thought in 1927 still notice the same year in which
I can bomb is writing his theory of the formal method and the same year in which
Benyamin visit Moscow and other,
it's a period of real continued social and intellectual ferment ferment within
the framework of Marxist government.
In 1927 wrote a book called the historical novel.
And this book is as though it were taken from angles,
his letters.
It's partly an attack on what Luke Hodge took to be the sort of narcissistic
inwardness of high modernism,
particularly Joyce and Proust.
It's a tendentious attack,
uh,
and certainly subject to criticism on all sorts of grounds.
It's partly that,
but it's also just in the way that angle's championed Balzac in his letters.
It's a book that champions the novels of Sir Walter Scott Scott too was a
political reactionary,
a Tory,
but who's great toward of dialectical balances in his novels between Highland
and Loland feudal and Merck until Scotland and England,
whose balances of,
uh,
an old social order with an emerging social order.
Lucot took to be perfect example of vacations,
of what realism of seeing class relations as they really are,
can do.
And so this is the tradition of realist aesthetics in Marxist criticism.
But then as really dating from 1927 precisely,
uh,
with the rise of Stalin,
things began to change,
at least in the Soviet sphere.
And the original ideas of all these people who used to write to angles,
minecart ski non novelists,
all writers of that kind began to prevail in Soviet thought.
There was a literary critic named not off,
uh,
who articulated a doctrine of Soviet,
of socialist realism.
Um,
even the,
even Marxists critics themselves in,
in those days divided the sort of,
the joke about the sort of novel that she's not off had in mind.
Uh,
you probably know the joke.
boy meets tractor,
uh,
boy loses tractor,
boy goes to the city to find tractor fines.
Tractor,
uh,
continues to be in love,
takes tractor back to the countryside and lives happily ever after this
fundamental plot.
Uh,
obviously a variant on the marriage plot,
uh,
but very much engaged also in,
what bank would call the mechanical aspect of reproduction.
Uh,
this,
this sort of plot as the characteristic plot of up socialist realism,
uh,
began to take hold officially.
So that,
um,
in 1934,
a,
the Soviet Culture Minister Bukharin a convened an international Soviet writers
conference in which it was simply decreed from on high that hence forth,
uh,
literary practice would consist in,
the promotion of an exemplification of socialist realism.
Uh,
and since then,
really right up until the fall of the iron curtain in 1989 since then,
uh,
there really was a form of censorship,
abroad,
uh,
in Soviet and Soviet sphere societies,
to the effect that,
uh,
literature was subject to challenge,
possibly to suppress and if PR to suppression if it didn't here to a socialist
realist tenants.
So those are the forms of realism that I think are most often identified with
Marxist criticism and it's possibilities.
But as a matter of fact,
probably the most dynamic criticism since Lou couch,
uh,
of the 20th century has recognized that realism,
something that after all,
from a Marxist perspective,
can easily be shown to have been commandeered by the Borzois z.
Who else tells it like it is,
who else insist that reality is just one drink below par?
Who else insists that,
uh,
that he or she is a realist other than the characteristic?
Um,
so middleclass per person,
uh,
who tells you that they've been there,
done that and know everything that there is to know.
Uh,
the middleclass in other words,
from the standpoint of much Marxists thought since,
uh,
[inaudible],
um,
has,
uh,
commandeered for itself just as a common deer.
Everything else for itself has commandeered for itself the idea of realism,
which has therefore become in these views,
uh,
outmoded aesthetically.
Now,
Benyamin is himself acutely conscious of this problem and he insists,
uh,
that a realism,
in a variety of ways is a kind of late capitalist,
uh,
form of commodifying the aura.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
it is the last gasp of a bourgeois art and a variety of ways.
He says,
hopefully,
uh,
and it needs to be counteracted with what he takes to be a participatory
aesthetic,
an aesthetic,
uh,
of the fragment and aesthetic of a intermittent attention of,
um,
participation,
which does not,
uh,
nevertheless,
in any way involve a sense of persisting Lee,
uh,
contemplating that which is real.
But [inaudible] emphasizes rather,
uh,
the idea that one is oneself in a communal spirit and gauged with the very mode
of production of the work of art.
Uh,
and somehow or another involved in that,
that's what we'll come back to when we turn to Benu means work of our essay.
Perhaps the most unusual aesthetic moved for a Marxist criticism.
Marx's critic is the one that you will find in Adorno.
Adorno was devoted to precisely what Lou Kotch had attacked in the historical
novel,
namely the high modernist aesthetic.
He admired Beckett in literature.
He admired Suran bear bear.
They Barron in music.
Uh,
Adorno was by training a musicologist and he devoted much of his writing career,
uh,
to,
producing essays and treatises on music and the history of music.
Uh,
these were heroes in Adorno's Pantheon.
And of course,
the question arises,
how can,
how can these people who have nothing to say about society,
Ah,
who are totally preoccupied with form,
who seem to be indifferent to the whole course of history?
How can these people be the aesthetic heroes of a Marxist critic?
This is something you see much more clearly in the fetish character,
a essay,
uh,
from which I've given you the two excerpts,
which I hope you have.
And I want to pause over them because I think Adorno's essay,
while perhaps a little quixotic because after all,
whoever could profit from a concept of this kind that a effort essay is
nevertheless rather brilliant in its distinction between the totality or
wholeness that's offered to you by artistic form and the mirror total ization or
totalitarianism that's offered to you by modern hedgematic had had demonic forms
of government,
whether truly totalitarian or insidiously totalitarian,
like for example,
the culture industry to which he devotes the essay that you've read.
Um,
so this is what Adorno says in these two passages.
he's talking about the way in which,
uh,
people,
the people in the culture industry,
uh,
who appreciate music are completely victimized by the coloratura local effect.
Uh,
what you might call this is a conductor whom Adorno hated the Toscanini effect.
that flourishing of a particular moment in a concerto,
the writing it into the ground at the expense of the whole,
everything that has everything that has,
uh,
what Adorno elsewhere calls lip smacking you funny,
that sort of in a,
in other words,
I kind of cultivation of perfection of local sound as opposed to an awareness of
the total composition.
So he says in the first passage,
the delight in the moment and the gay facade become an excuse for absolving the
listener from the thought of the whole whose claim is comprised in proper
listening,
the listener is converted along his line of least resistance because after all,
it's so beautiful to listen to a converted along his line of least resistance
into the acquiescent purchasing no longer do the partial moments serve as a
critique of the whole,
as they sometimes do in modernism.
Dissonance,
in other words is in and of itself a critique of that overarching harmony with
which we associate wholeness,
right?
So there's a real sense in which the parts can be understood as a critique of
the whole without challenging or breaking down the whole,
uh,
no longer do the partial moment serve as a critique of the whole.
Instead they suspend the critique which the successful aesthetic totality exerts
against the flawed one of society.
In other words,
nothing can criticize the
inauthenticity of the bad totalities of society.
Then the authenticity of a genuine achieved wholeness in a work of art.
The difference between these senses of the hole is precisely the zone of
critique,
which in a drawer view might just might awaken the,
uh,
the victim of the culture industry,
from the slumbers of happy conformism and acquiescence.
Now,
in the second passage,
just to reinforce this great modernist composers like Barrick shirt and,
and very burn are called individualists by other Marxist critics and other words
by people like Luca who don't like this sort of,
you know,
this,
what [inaudible] would call fetishization of form reification of form.
At the expense of social reference and expression.
And yet their work is nothing but a single dialogue with the powers that destroy
individuality.
Powers who's formless shadows fall gigantically on their music in music to
collective powers are liquidating and individuality,
past saving,
but against them.
Only individuals are capable of consciously representing the aid,
the aims of collectivity.
In other words,
uh,
the,
the totality,
the achieved successful,
authentic totality of the work of art models,
the totality of a collective state in ways that none of the false totalities of
current had Geminis can possibly do or even approximate.
In other words,
there is an implicit politics in Adorno's argument in pure form.
The achievement of pure form,
which is after all a collection of parts is an implicit politics modeling the
achievement of a collective society.
Right?
So that is the argument of Adorno.
It's a fascinating one.
As I say,
it's perhaps somewhat quixotic because it's kind of hard to imagine anyone
actually,
uh,
sort of listening to Sharon bag and saying,
gee,
maybe I should be a communist.
You know?
I mean,
yes.
You know,
there's sort of,
I actually actually putting this to work in other words,
uh,
you know,
entails and tells a certain amount of difficulty.
Uh,
but at the same time,
I mean,
intellectually it seems to me to be a fascinating turn of thought and one that
certainly does give one pause a,
uh,
if only because I'm a Marxist criticism is so often and gauged in a critique of
what it takes to be the mainstream aesthetic of Western civilization,
which is a kind of Fetis fetishization of wholeness.
Think of the new criticism,
the unity of the poem,
the discreet ontological object as a unified whole.
Uh,
this is of course a commonplace,
uh,
in being attacked by Marxists criticism.
And it's very interesting to see in a figure like Adorno a champion of this very
wholeness who,
whose,
who sees it as a model,
not of a narcissistic individuality,
but rather of call activity.
All right.
And finally,
uh,
and I won't pause much over this because it's going to be the subject of
Thursday's lecture.
The last option for aesthetic option for Marxism is a surprising one.
And it actually goes back to a book by Arentz block called the principle of
hope,
uh,
in which block essentially argues,
in,
uh,
the world as we have it.
Um,
in other words,
the grinding down of hope,
uh,
the,
the grant,
the grinding down of possibility for all in late capitalism,
there is no longer,
uh,
any hope available,
kind of,
uh,
kind of gloomy a prognosis with which,
block,
um,
uh,
counters the idea that especially in folk art folk ways,
oral culture,
uh,
and in popular culture,
in other words,
and the expressions of logging one fines in the work of the dispossessed and the
o pressed there is a kind of utopianism,
a romance,
a sense,
not so much of wishing for something past,
even though it,
it seems to take the form of nostalgia,
but rather a projection of a possibility on the future,
which is simply unavailable.
And the real world,
of course,
the best example I can think of as the Big Rock Candy Mountain,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
this is sun.
This is,
this is a song sung by people on chain gangs.
Uh,
about,
you know,
liquor running down the sides of mountains and rivulets and you know,
everything just as it should be.
Uh,
the Big Rock Candy Mountain in other words,
is a perfect example of,
um,
a youth of,
of,
of the principle of hope as a,
as block understands it.
This is something that's picked up and taken very seriously by Frederic Jameson.
Not so much in the excerpt from the political con,
from the political unconscious that you'll be reading for the lecture.
But in an earlier part of that introductory chapter,
uh,
in which he talks about the importance of romance,
replacing the bankrupt aesthetic of realism,
the aesthetic of realism that has been appropriated by the bourgeoisie and as
expression,
expressing in a seemingly hopeless world,
uh,
the hopes of the oppressed and the dispossessed.
Uh,
so this too,
the idea of romance,
the idea of the,
of,
of Utopian evocation,
uh,
is,
a last viable aesthetic for,
um,
a certain turn of Marx's thought,
which has been interesting and productive in the 20th century.
All right,
so today we take up numbers two and three,
the participatory aesthetic of Benyamin.
And the modernist totality of Adorno,
uh,
and we see the way in which they conflict with each other.
Now in some ways,
I wish we were still reading the fetish character essay because it has more to
do with aesthetics than the excerpt you have in your book by Adorno and
Horkheimer called the culture industry.
But the culture industry to,
uh,
is a response as was the fetish character in music which was published 1938 to
Banyan means work of art in the age of mechanical reproduction.
Adorno who was a close friend of venue means and who exchanged letters about
Benny means work of our essay with him,
letters by the way,
which were republished in the new left review of 1973.
Those of you who are interested in looking at them,
because this is another source of,
of ways of seeing how Benyamin uh,
and Adorno we're in conflict over this matter.
Uh,
uh,
Datto and Benyamin,
as I say,
we're a very close friends.
Uh,
Benyamin,
uh,
was only for a relatively brief period in the 1930s,
a Marxist critic.
Uh,
he had hitherto been much more interested in a cabalistic literature in the
Hungarian tradition of philosophy.
Uh,
and even in the 1930s,
he was famously torn,
uh,
between two possibilities.
He had visited Moscow in 1926 27 he had become interested in what was still,
after all,
as I've said,
a vibrant culture,
uh,
in,
the Soviet world.
Um,
and at the same time he had become very close friends with the Marxist
playwright Bertolt Brecht and I had fallen also very much under his influence.
But another very close friend of friend,
equally influential was the,
uh,
Jewish theologian Guercio.
I'm showing them who had emigrated to Jerusalem,
uh,
who was a Zionist and who wanted Benyamin to join him,
studying,
uh,
the Torah in Jerusalem,
and to,
uh,
engage himself in that community as opposed to the sort of international Marxist
community toward which toward which Benyamin was perhaps more leaning,
especially,
uh,
owing to his friendship with brackets.
So,
even in the 1930s,
even in the period when Brexit wrote his work of art essay and also a shorter,
even more tangential essay called the author as producer,
a 1936,
uh,
an essay in which he actually takes up linked something he mentions in passing
in the work of art essay.
That is to say the way in which,
uh,
in Russia,
everybody is judged not just for being able to do a job,
but for being able to talk about doing a job,
uh,
for,
to be able to write it up,
to describe it,
to write a brochure about it,
to write a letter to the paper about it.
Uh,
in other words,
to participate,
uh,
to be engaged not just in the labor force,
but also in reflections on the labor force in a way that really does mean that
everyone can be an author.
And also that every author is a producer.
That is to say engaged in writing,
which is part and parcel of the productions of labor.
Uh,
all of this was a focus of venue mean,
but at the same time,
even within this focus,
uh,
there,
he,
part of him is being torn in another direction.
No one can for a minute.
In reading the work of art essay fail to notice that Benyamin Eve events is
tremendous nostalgia for the aura.
It's not an easy thing for our,
for Benyamin to say,
we have to tear down the aura and replace it with a kind of participatory
participatory mode,
uh,
that,
engages with and is involved in mechanical reproduction.
I mean,
I don't know,
when I was a student,
I worked on and off,
I did this for years,
um,
in an art supply and picture framing store,
uh,
on the Berkeley campus.
And,
uh,
of course every student needed a picture,
putting his room.
And so we had huge stacks of Van Gogh's,
sunflowers and uh,
Matisse's dancers and certain other paintings.
All of them 18 by 24,
which we call brushstroke prints.
They were,
they were mounted on cardboard,
ah,
and a huge home cookie cutter of some kind would come down on top of them.
Actually laminating into the print,
the appearance of brush strokes,
uh,
and these things,
if you squinted at the beginning of a semester,
would you,
you saw the stack going down like this.
In other words,
you,
you know,
and then before you knew it,
the stacks were gone.
And so you knew for a fact,
because you knew how many prints were in that stack,
that,
you know,
240 students rooms were festooned with van Gogh's,
sunflowers,
Matisse's dancers.
And you said to yourself,
this is the fruit of mechanical reproduction,
you know,
this,
and,
and you asked yourself again,
just,
you know,
just what is the value of this as an authentic,
as an aesthetic.
Yeah.
Takes it out of the museum.
It means that nobody has to pay,
um,
you know,
50 bucks in order to stand,
to,
to wait in a long line in order to get a peep at the Mona Lisa.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
it really does bring it home to the people,
but how,
and in what way?
And at the expense of what genuine knowledge of art history and even a van Gogh
and mattise um,
does the fetishization because it is after all a fetishization of these little
mechanically reproduced brushstroke prints amount too.
Obviously this introduces complications and their complications.
The whole point of my anecdote there complications of which Benyamin is far from
being unaware.
He knows extremely well that,
um,
after all the greatest threat to an aesthetic of a kind he profounds is that it
can be commandeered by capital.
Of course,
I'm getting ahead of myself because that's precisely what Ardorno says in
opposition to him.
But in the meantime,
that was the situation of Benyamin and the 1930s Adorno in the meantime had gone
to the United States.
Benyamin was living in Paris ever since 1933.
Adorno had gone to the United States,
um,
which he hated.
I mean,
they,
the gloom of Adorno's view of the world is not so much the result of the,
of his experiences of that,
of the week forms of democracy and the Weimar Republic,
um,
sort of ominous as those experiences were not even perhaps so much their eyes of
nuts ism because like Benyamin he was able to flee that the gloom that he felt
and the gloom that pervades his writing,
which after all starts in the mid 1940s is the result of his exposure to
American culture.
He simply could not stand us or our culture.
Uh,
he couldn't stand jazz.
Remember,
this was,
this was not yet the age of Bebop and I've always felt that maybe if a donor
would hung around a little longer,
he could have,
he could have been reconciled.
It was,
no,
it was,
it was no longer the jazz of the APP.
Lee named director,
the conductor,
Paul White men,
you know,
it was,
it was jazz of,
of,
of that was some work somewhat more serious.
He couldn't stand the movies.
Um,
I've just been,
for purposes,
I won't go into watching a film called,
uh,
Broadway melody of 1940 with Fred Astaire and Eleanor Powell tap dancing and
Fred Astaire,
you know,
is sort of read and,
and,
and his sidekick,
George Murphy are sort of grabbed out of obscurity in order to be the leading
gentlemen of Eleanor Paul.
It's a perfect sort of Samuel smiles success story replete with,
uh,
the necessity of occasional self sacrifice on the part of both of them.
I mean,
it is,
it is made for the wrath of Adorno this film,
but it is,
um,
it is at,
and it's nevertheless in ways that Adorno could not possibly ever,
uh,
come to feel quite charming.
Um,
but,
but Adorno wanted no part of American culture.
And he was,
uh,
in anticipation of that whole trend of American sociology,
obsessed with,
um,
the way in which,
uh,
American society is dominated by conformism.
He takes this to be the effect,
the result of the pervasive,
um,
oh,
oppressive thumb of the culture industry,
so that our very eccentricities are very quirks and little originality.
He's all of them are assessed carefully by the culture industry.
A niche is found for them.
And the next thing you know,
we're suborned just like everybody else.
There is a in four Adorno,
uh,
no sideways escape from the Monolithic,
a ubiquitous surveillance and dominance of the culture industry.
All right.
Now the work of art in the age of mechanical reproduction,
um,
is influenced obviously by the promise of Russian art before 1934.
The films a very tough,
uh,
in particular,
and other ways in which it's possible for Benyamin to say that the spectator
really can be a participant.
It's possible for Benyamin to say that in such context.
It's a good thing that the pedestal in the,
the,
the pedestals aura of the work of art has been successfully torn down that we no
longer stand in rapturous attention bef uh,
and in contemplative postures before works of art.
But that we,
uh,
reach out to them and they reached out to us.
We meet halfway and we become engaged with them.
We become part of them.
Now how does this work in this essay?
Primarily through the insertion of the Labor function of the apparatus in the
represented field.
Now this is a complicated idea that Benyamin develops in various ways,
but what he means by this is that the spectator sees the object sees whatever
the field in question is from the perspective of the mode of production data is
to say that what the perspective the spectator participates by joining the
process of production.
Most obviously this means that when I watch a film,
I see the film necessarily of course from the standpoint of the camera eye,
my eye,
in other words joins that of the camera.
Very interesting that in Berlin and the 1930s Christopher itches issue would in
his Berlin stories,
uh,
wrote one story called I'm a camera taking place in Berlin.
I've often thought there's some sort of symbiosis between the notion,
uh,
I am a camera,
in Christopher Isherwood and the way in which it may be appropriate,
it or it may simply be a happy coincidence,
uh,
and the work of Benyamin.
But in a certain sense for Benyamin the spectator to be a participant is the
camera is,
in other words,
the camera's eye.
What is the consequence of this?
Well,
the spectator is in a certain sense then a critic Benyamin keeps comparing the
eye of the camera with a test.
He even compares it with the vocational aptitude test.
It says though,
what in the theater would count as an audition.
I appeared before the director.
I recite certain lines of the script and I'm either uh,
told to come back another day or I'm given the part what that it,
it's as though to substitute what counts as an audition with the perpetual
audition of the film actor before the camera.
Because after all there's the camera recording what the film actor is doing.
But the camera,
not this camera up here by the way,
but ordinarily the camera has the opera,
the option of later on throwing out what is it any good?
I would that they could,
uh,
but,
but the,
but the film camera can edit the film camera as part of an editing process so
that the actor in front of the camera is perpetually being tested,
auditioned in just the way that,
uh,
you might be tested or audition if you took a vocational aptitude test for a job
that's been you means point.
And what he means to say is that if the spectator then takes the camera's eye
position,
the spectator,
him or herself,
then becomes a critic like a sports fan then and mean doesn't pretend for a
moment that to become a critic of this kind is to be a good critic.
Not at all,
not at all by any mean agrees with people that we the WHO say,
well,
we go to the movies when we're tired.
All we want is to be entertained.
In fact,
we are distracted.
We are critics as Benyamin argues in a state of distraction.
The German word is sash steroid junk.
We are self steroid and we're perpetually,
in other words,
uh,
not quite paying attention even while at the same time we are seeing things from
the camera eye point of view to see things from the camera.
I'll come back to distraction and a minute to see things from the camera.
Eye Point of view is a position of privilege because it exposes as Benyamin
tells us again and again things about reality that we wouldn't otherwise notice.
The camera is capable of slow motion.
It's capable of angles of incidents that we couldn't otherwise see.
It's capable of all kinds of effects.
Let me enumerate them.
I think it's on page.
Uh,
photographic reproduction,
top of the left end hall.
I'm photographic reproduction with the aid of certain processes such as
enlargement or slow motion can capture images which escaped natural vision.
And on page 1245,
he gives this process a name.
He says the camera introduces us to unconscious optics.
Optics just as does psychoanalysis to unconscious impulses.
In other words,
the camera's eye point of view is a privileged perspective.
It does show us things as they are or perhaps if not as they are,
at least it reminds us that things as we see them with the naked eye aren't
necessarily as they are.
I mean,
it's not perhaps so much of a notion of privileging what the camera sees as real
over against what I see.
It's a question of the camera reminding us,
demystifying our ideology in short,
reminding us that things as we see them aren't necessarily the way things are.
The too may have,
it's biased.
Slow motion is an obvious bias.
Speed up as an obvious bias,
but the speed at which we things see things may be a bias too.
That's the point of the expo.
I mean it's not that,
it's not that the psychoanalytic unconscious is telling the truth.
I mean dreams are crazy,
right?
That's the whole point of dreams.
It's not that it's,
it's not that it's reality over against a mystified world scene in
consciousness.
It's a challenge to consciousness by the world evoked in the unconscious,
not a question of what's real and what isn't real well,
it's the same with the camera's eye point of view and it's all of this which
awakens in a certain sense awakens the spectator from the complacency of
supposing his or her own perspective to be the truth at the same time.
Admittedly the spectator is,
is distracted self steroid.
Well what then the point is this,
there's a kind of dialectic between distraction and shock,
which is crucial.
Vanderveen Benyamin thanks to a genuine,
uh,
re aesthetic revelation.
Uh,
perhaps the best analogy is with Saul on the road to Damascus.
You know how the story goes.
Saul's trotting along on his horse and you know,
not paying a lot of attention is distracted,
daydreaming,
whatever,
and all of a sudden he falls off his horse.
All right?
That's a shock and it's such a shock that he's converted to Christianity and he
stands up and he brushes himself off and his name is Paul,
right?
He's,
he's a completely different person,
you know,
as a result,
and this couldn't have happened.
In other words,
if he hadn't been distracted,
right?
That's been your mains point.
Distraction is the atmosphere or medium in which the shock of revelation can
take place.
And that's the advantage of distraction.
He gives a wonderful example of the way in which we do receive works of art in
distraction.
Even if ordinary.
I mean,
even if we're the kind of person who does pay a lot of attention when they go to
the movies and we go,
oh,
that's not me.
We say,
nevertheless,
there is one way in which all of us receive works of art in a State of
distraction.
And that's in our reception of architecture.
We pass through architecture.
I mean,
I work in the British arts centre every day.
I long since ceased to pay any attention to the British art center as a
building.
Uh,
I'd,
I received the British arts centre,
in other words,
in a state of distraction.
But that doesn't mean that it's not part of my aesthetic experience.
It does,
however,
show that the aesthetic and the,
and,
and the ways in which the ways in which we process the forms of the world can be
assimilated in more than one kind of state of attention.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
in one's bones in a certain sense to receive architecture.
And yet at the same time,
uh,
unless we are sort of tourists gaping in front of the Taj Mahal with a camera,
something like that.
And,
and,
and Benyamin does take that into account unless we are in that particular mode.
We received the forms of our dwellings and a state of what you might call
constructive distraction.
All of that goes in to Banyan means aesthetic of participation.
Now,
I am out of time,
perhaps I've said just about as much about Adorno as I need to say,
although admittedly I haven't said much about the culture industry essay.
Uh,
maybe I'll come back to that briefly,
uh,
before launching into Jameson on Thursday.
On Tuesday of next week,
we'll be talking about the new historicism and then we'll bring Tony back.
Uh,
and we'll go through all of these various perspectives that we will have been
rehearsing,
uh,
to see what we can do with them.
When we read Toni.